Support vector machines is often referred
to as SVM for short.
Support vector machines is a classifier that
finds an optimal hyperplane that maximizes
the margin between two classes.
Let's start with a very basic example with
only two dimensions.
Using X1 and X2, we want a line to separate
the red squares from the blue circles.
So, any line shown on this plot is really
a viable option.
They would all perfectly separate the red
squares from the blue circles.
However, there has to be an optimal line,
or decision boundary.
In other words, what line would give us the
best chance to correctly classify additional
examples in each of these two classes?
You would probably want a line that is evenly
spaced between these two classes to give a
little bit of buffer for each class.
That's exactly what support vector machines
does.
The definition sounds fancy, but really, you're
just trying to find a line that's right in
the middle of your two classes, evenly spaced
between the two.
Mathematically, it's defined as maximizing
the margin between your decision boundary
and the closest points.
Now, you might be wondering where this support
vector terminology comes from.
Support vector is the name for the perpendicular
line from your decision boundary to your closest
points in both classes.
On the right, it's the perpendicular line
that goes from that green optimal hyperplane
to those filled-in points, that filled-in
blue circle and the filled-in red squares.
The goal is to maximize the length of those
support vectors.
In the example on the left, visually we can
see that non of these is the ideal decision
boundary.
You can see how close these closest points
in each class are to the decision boundary,
so the algorithm wouldn't like these as the
optimal solution.
What SVM is seeking to do, is maximize that
distance between the decision boundary and
the nearest points.
In our definition, we talked about finding
an optimal hyperplane.
In our examples, we've just been using a line
in 2 dimensional space.
So, a hyperplane is just a generalized term
to identify your decision boundary in an n
dimensional space.
So, in two dimensions, that's just a line.
In 3 dimension, it is a plane and so on.
Up to this point, everything we've discussed
requires our data to be linearly separable,
so we're using a straight line to separate
out examples in two-dimensional space, and
we are using a flat hyperplane to separate
examples in a three-dimensional space.
We're not using any curved lines or curved
hyperplanes.
So, what happens when we have data that can't
be separated by a straight line or a hyperplane?
That leads us to this really creative trick
called the kernel trick.
This transform our data which is not linearly
separable in n-dimensional space into a higher
dimension where it is linearly separable.
Let's look at an example Here, we're trying
to identify the presence of cancer based on
gene X and gene Y.
This data clearly is not linearly separable
in two dimensions.
We couldn't draw a straight line here that
would separate the blue from the red.
We would need a circle in order to do that.
However, if we were to project this data from
two-dimensional space into three-dimensional
space like this, all of a sudden now we can
use a flat hyperplane to split our data very
nicely to identify the presence of cancer.
So, that's the kernel trick, and it's a really
powerful tool for support vector machines.
When should you consider using SVM?
SVM can be used for both categorical and continuous
outputs, but it is not be very useful for
regression.
It should only be a focus when you're working
on a classification problem with some kind
of binary target variable.
One area where SVM really excels is when the
feature-to-row ratio is very high.
This is what we called short and fat data
previously.
It's when you have a lot of features and relatively
few rows.
Many algorithms will really suffer from these,
but SVM tends to do fairly well, and it's
actually one of its distinguishing features.
SVM is also quite good at untangling complex
relationships.
SVM also handles data with a lot of outliers
quite well.
If you think about how SVM works using these
support vectors it actually makes sense, because
it only looks at the points closest to the
line, so that outliers are kind of ignored.
So, if you're working with data with a lot
of outliers, and many other algorithms are
struggling, you might want to consider SVM.
When should you not use it?
You should not use it if you have a lot of
rows and relatively few features.
Typically, SVM will take a long time to train,
and the performance really won't be worth
it relative to other algorithms.
Despite the really nice plots that we saw
before, when you’re dealing with hundreds
of features, and the hyperplane is an extremely
high-dimensional space, you can't really get
a good picture what's going on inside of SVM.
So, if you care about transparency, and maybe
the significance of predictors, you would
probably avoid SVM.
Lastly, if you're looking for a quick benchmark
model, SVM probably is not the right choice.
SVM take quite a long time to train, and it
takes longer than other algorithms to make
predictions as well.
You really want to avoid SVM if time or maybe
compute power is a significant constraint.
In summary, SVM should be used when you have
a lot of features, but few rows, or when you
have a lot of outliers, that you're trying
to untangle.
But it is quite slow to train, you might want
to look somewhere else.